hey everyone i'm abby schart welcome to
abby's kitchen on today's
youtuber review we will be looking at a
heavily requested video
by sorel amore called my dietary
nutrition guidelines
now sarela mora has been on youtube for
12 years
and now teaches other youtube hopefuls
with her public figure boot camp her
advanced
selfie university and her grow your
instagram like me course
she now lives in a beautiful home in
iceland and despite being an
influencer expert in july she mentioned
that she was giving her audience an
eight-month warning
of her quitting youtube sorel suggested
that as a social media influencer
she feels that she is always on and is
unable to ever live in the moment and
because of that
she's just been thinking about quitting
for a really long time
honestly i hear that and i feel that so
so much honestly there isn't a day that
goes by that i
don't wonder if any of this is worth
doing because
the stress and pressure of this strange
public life
is really overwhelming but now in an
interest to keep this video from being
like
five hours long i had to pick and choose
what i'm showing
today i did watch a white in a day video
from sorel
as well as a water fasting video from
back in may
plus a lot of her other content but i
want to focus mainly on the video that i
was sent
like a hundred times because there is
just
so much to unpack on that alone
now before we start a few quick
disclaimers the information in this
video is for educational and
entertainment purposes only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs number two any of the
recommendations that i give for meals is
really just meant to give you some ideas
on how to add balance and variety and
satiety to your meals and snacks
whether or not one individual meal or
even one day is balanced
or healthy really doesn't matter in the
grand scheme of one's health
especially if a person is eating in
response to their physical
and emotional needs basically i give
suggestions as examples and inspiration
for you
but you could also gather this data for
yourself
over time simply by listening to your
own body
also keep in mind that i watch a lot of
a youtuber's content
but i cannot capture a youtuber's entire
catalog of content
so this is not an all-encompassing
review
also please be kind in the comments both
here and on sorel's channel
and a trigger warning a big trigger
warning that some graphics and some
discussions
may be disturbing to some of my viewers
especially those who
come from disordered eating backgrounds
so um
definitely feel free to skip this video
if you feel like that may trigger you
and of course a big reminder to
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget to ring that little
bell so you never miss out on a video
so without a do let's get into it
oh god honestly i didn't even like the
original quote as i find it kind of
reduces food to mirror nutrients and
fuel
and we know that it plays so many more
important roles than that
but sorrell's version is like truly
cringe-worthy
i can't imagine thinking of our
beautiful world as
poisoned especially the gorgeous iceland
that she lives in
um as for the organic insert well we're
going to talk a lot more about that
very soon i'm strict on the food we eat
because i have to counterbalance the
amount of poison that is in our food and
our atmosphere in our water so this is
why i put so much emphasis on eating the
right fruits but it shouldn't be this
difficult i shouldn't call myself strict
the way that i'm eating is
more so a normal diet the way that we
should be eating okay so just prior to
this clip sorel discusses how exercise
is not the reason for her fit
physique but rather it's a combination
of her having a natural
small body and the fact that she is
strict
with the food that she eats and as we
hear here
the reason she is strict is because she
feels she needs to counterbalance the
amount of
poison in our food water and environment
honestly i take real issue with the use
of the word
poison this perception of food as poison
or toxic
or something to be feared and carefully
surveilled
is at the root of what we now know of as
orthorexia
aka an unhealthy obsession with healthy
eating
i'm in no means diagnosing sorel with
any kind of disorder
but i do find that this fear-mongering
as it pertains to the food in our food
system
is incredibly triggering and
unnecessarily
anxiety promoting and telling people
that this uncompromising approach to
food
is not only not strict but how we should
eat
or a normal diet can lead a lot of
vulnerable
viewers down a potentially really
dangerous rabbit hole in their
relationship with food
i actually have a lot of empathy for
somebody who has to
go through their whole life fearful of
food
i have to say that uh we're not off to a
really good start
no sugar elimination of sugar is one of
the most important things that you can
do for yourself
confectionary additives and sauces
ketchup read the labels around
five grams or under is okay and now when
we're looking at fruits and vegetables
eliminating a little bit of
fruits as well this is hard for me to
admit because i am
a fruitaholic i used to be and the thing
is the closer you are to the equator the
more fruits
you're able to eat but the further away
you go the less you should be consuming
because it's not natural for fruits to
be in that area so
just because it's healthy in some areas
of the world doesn't make it healthy in
other areas of the world
and that is talking about carbohydrates
guess what bread is guess what pasta is
yet when it's broken down
it turns into sugar wow there's a lot to
tackle in like just a minute worth of
footage
um so i'm not surprised that sorelle's
first diet rule is to cut out sugar
her definition of what a reasonable
amount of sugar is
is less than 5 grams per 100 gram
portion
now in contrast most health authorities
recommend no more than 10
of calories from free sugars aka added
sugars
so free sugars are those that are not
bound to other nutrients that help
slow down their digestion and absorption
so
that means that we could find free
sugars in things like honey
or white sugar or candy but not in
things like fruit or milk or yogurt
where these sugars are bound up with
fiber or protein or fat
so at best if sorella is just referring
to free sugar
her guidelines are already twice as
restrictive
as those of major health authorities but
then she goes on to also suggest that we
limit fruit
and tell us about how when carbs are
broken down they turn into sugar
so now i'm not sure if she's telling us
to limit all carbs to less than five
percent of calories
or five percent of a serving size of
food but unless she's suggesting that we
all go hardcore keto
that is just not enough the strangest
thing about her recommendation is that
she goes on to say
that the closer you are to the equator
the more fruits you
can eat but the further away you live
the less fruit you can eat because it's
not
natural for fruits to grow there uh
that is so misinformed and like
so unusual i had to listen to it back
five times or more to
really grasp what she was saying first
of all
humans have evolved to find ways to
enjoy a variety of fruits and vegetables
to make it easier and more enjoyable to
meet our varied
nutrient needs this includes flash
freezing fruits when they're ripe and
out of season
so that we can enjoy it later on in the
year also
i live in canada and we live nowhere
near the
equator so does that mean that i
shouldn't have
any fruit the reality is we grow
a lot of beautiful fruit outside here in
canada we've got apples and pears in the
fall and strawberries and peaches in the
summer etc
and if we look back in history our first
nations ancestors relied on freshly
foraged wild berries
as quick nutrient dense fuel and we eat
all of these local fruits
despite the fact that again we live 7
000 kilometers away from the equator
girl
this serie just doesn't hold up
finally sorel mentions that because
sugar is addictive
if you cut it out for a month your
palate will change and you won't crave
it anymore
now i'm not going to spend so much time
on this one because i already have a
whole video
on the science of sugar addiction which
you can check out right here
but while the research is contradictory
and very complicated
hence why i needed a whole long video to
explain it
while i do think we can train our pal to
appreciate more subtle sweetness
in fruits and vegetables and other less
hyper-sweet foods by
eating less refined sugar the research
has not
yet convinced me that we can retrain our
brain
especially when there's a heavily
restrictive mentality going on
everyone likes to talk about the rat
research on sugar having a dopamine
response in the brain
but the researchers actually only
observed this response
when the animals had been previously
restricted of sugar
in other words when we restrict sugar
heavily we see
obsessive and binge-like tendencies the
moment we
finally do have access to that sugar
it basically increases the reward value
of that food
i also just want to point out that in
her april what in a day video
she had two oreos for dessert which i
have zero qualms about
nutritionally especially after she ate
like a massive six liter mason jar of
salad for lunch
but it was a surprising choice
considering
how dogmatic she is now being about
going
free liquids mostly water pure water
three years ago
i was like what is water it actually
doesn't matter tap water everywhere of
course it doesn't matter
having pure water is a necessity having
filters on your water super important
the language this woman uses
literally reads like the actual
definition of orthorexia
clean toxic pure it's a lot
um again i'm not saying any of it is
problematic for her
but man i know
why you all sent this video to me in
such haste now
as for the insistence that you need pure
water and
use a water filter to get it this
largely depends on where you live and
what your community's treatment of your
tap water is like so most water filters
use
activated carbon to absorb metals like
lead
copper and mercury chemicals like
chlorine and pesticides
and organic compounds that can affect
the taste and smell of your water
having said that most tap water in most
municipalities
has already been treated to remove
bacteria and any harmful microorganisms
and dissolved minerals in water really
aren't
toxic anyway also if you aren't changing
that filter regularly according to the
manufacturer's recommendations
your water may actually be more
contaminated
than it was when it came out of the tap
so yes
a too old filter can easily add bacteria
to your water
because a moist filter is a hot bed
for bacterial growth one study even
found that after just one week of filter
use
the amount of bacteria was greater in
the filtered water
than the straight up tap water uh
yikes now if it's a tasting that's a
preference and a filter
may or may not improve it but ultimately
whether or not your tap water is safe to
drink will depend on where you live
or how your community treats its water
but i will say most tap water in
industrialized communities does meet
proper sanitation standards
and is very safe to drink my
recommendation is to check with your
local water utility services
for their consumer confidence report and
if you're still unsure
you can have your water independently
tested for specific contaminants
bottom line use a filter if it's to
improve the taste of your water
but know that these don't really kill
bacteria
and if too much time goes between filter
changes
it may actually make your water less
safe
okay so let's see what other food rules
she lives by
so mostly i consume two to three liters
of water a day then i have one
bulletproof coffee in the morning and
then i have
organic tea two or three times a day no
juices because the amount of sugar there
is in that
all right so sorel says that she has two
to three liters
of pure water a day then her bulletproof
coffee
made with organic freshly ground coffee
organic coconut oil organic coconut milk
almond butter uh-oh i don't know if that
one's organic
but she's also got lion's mane mushrooms
turkey tail mushrooms
l-theanine uh organic honey and shilajit
she also has of course no juices or soda
so i'm not surprised about the no juice
or soda rule since her first rule was no
sugar
although not to call her out on her own
bs set of restrictions
but in her may water fast video she has
juice as her last
meal before she attempts a three day
water fast
i also thought she said she wasn't
having any sugar but spoiler alert folks
honey is sugar and your body processes
it
virtually as it does white sugar
regardless of it being a
natural more nutrient dense option but
anyways
this is a unique take on bulletproof
coffee um we've at least got some
healthy fats
fiber and protein in the almond butter
in addition to
the classic coconut oil which is
traditionally used in bulletproof coffee
for its medium chain triglycerides or
mcts
which do have some modest fat burning
properties
unfortunately most coconut oil only
contains about
50 mcts and the mct that it's most rich
in
lauric acid doesn't appear to have as
many of those
ketogenic benefits compared to capiric
acid
or capric acid both of which together
only make up around 12 percent of its
fat
as for the medicinal mushrooms lion's
mane mushrooms is
often used as an adaptogenic ingredient
and research done on rats and mice
have shown that it may help to reduce
anxiety
depression and improve cognitive
function
turkey tail mushrooms are packed with
antioxidants and one review of the
research on humans with cancer
found that one to three point six grams
of daily mushrooms
reduced the risk of five-year mortality
by nine percent
definitely exciting though we don't
really know what the relevance is
in non-cancer patients they're also rich
in prebiotic fiber and have been found
to reduce harmful e coli bacteria in the
gut
so sure that is a worthy benefit as well
now the l-theanine she added is another
relaxing amino acid
and there is some research to support
its use for anxiety
and depression while the combination of
theanine and caffeine
may have a synergistic effect in
promoting cognition
and attention finally shilajit is an
ayurvedic
supplement packed with antioxidants
which early research on mice
suggests may help to naturally boost
energy levels and promote heart health
all of this sounds great and healthy yes
but evidence in support of these
supplements done on healthy humans
is hugely lacking and some of these
supplements may actually be harmful
depending on your unique health
conditions and medications
so always speak to a healthcare provider
about your
unique healthcare needs before just
ordering them on amazon
and throwing them into your morning
routine i eat organic whenever possible
yes i know i am in a position where i
can afford this but honestly when i
wasn't in a
luxury position of having accumulated
wealth through hard work i was still
hunting down as much organic food as i
could it wasn't very much that i could
afford
but i still tried as much as possible to
go to farmers markets and buy locally
hopefully those foods were better than
what i would buy in a supermarket
oh okay this is the beast
organic guys this needs to be an entire
video or maybe like an entire video
series so please do not rip me apart for
not considering
all of the research and all the
arguments for and against organics
i have way too many thoughts and i am
just going to
pepper a few relevant ones in but just
know that what i am about to say
does not reflect the totality of what
i think is important to consider in the
organics versus conventional
debate first of all i want to preface
this by saying i am pro-organic and i'm
also
pro-conventional i think it's nice that
consumers have a choice
and i see the benefits of both options
for families
but i am not pro-shaming people for
their choices or for
demonizing options that are perfectly
healthy
nutrient dense safe and budget conscious
let's very quickly go over a few things
one people believe that organic food is
safer because it doesn't use
pesticides wrong organic farmers
can still use natural pesticides which
i'll speak
more to in a moment and one 2011 study
found that almost 40 percent of organic
samples
had synthetic pesticide residues on them
anyway
i don't think that we can deny that
synthetic pesticide exposure is
greater in conventional produce and that
the safety of some pesticides like
roundup
is up for debate but the current
research supports the belief
that the amount of pesticides that we
generally get in conventionally grown
food is officially deemed safe again
this is
so much more complicated and even i have
my own convictions and concerns
around excessive pesticide exposure but
i think sorel's position is a lot more
anxiety inducing
than needs be second is the commonly
held belief that organic food is
infinitely more nutritious a 2012 review
found that while organic food
may reduce pesticide exposure and the
risk of ingesting
some antibiotic resistant bacteria
organic food
does not appear to be significantly more
nutritious
then a 2012 meta-analysis found much of
the same results so
no differences in a lot of the minerals
or vitamins like vitamin c
or e but it did find that organics had
more antioxidants
and lower cadmium levels while
conventional produce
had higher protein levels there was also
2016 review which found greater amounts
of omega-3s in milk
that was organic but since milk isn't a
major source of omega-3s anyways
you kind of have to decide if it's worth
the price hike ultimately this is a
really tricky question to answer because
the results will likely vary depending
on the specific farmers
farming practices and again i am just
scratching the surface of this research
anyways
but anyway the third common belief is
that gmos are
dangerous to eat and organic inherently
means non-chemo which is true
now i get the fear over anything
artificial or man-produced
when it comes down to food and i also
appreciate people's hesitancy
to trust their government to do their
due diligence when money is obviously on
the line
but i just want to note that there is no
evidence to suggest that any gmo derived
food poses
health risks to the public gmos also
have some benefits like reducing
pesticide use
reducing food spoilage increasing
nutrient profiles in
some crops and in some cases increasing
yield for less land water and cost
this could help get more nutritious food
to food deserts
and other less affluent communities
which personally
i am all for research also suggests that
there are no major nutritional
differences between gmos
and non-gmos outside the crops that have
been specifically bred to be
nutritionally superior like golden rice
so golden rice for example
was developed with extra vitamin a to
support
communities where vitamin a deficiency
was a major problem
now on the topic of regulation it
actually can take seven to ten years of
testing before a new
gmo crop reaches the market which is why
there are so
few major gmo categories in some
countries like here in canada
however a lot of regulatory bodies are
not doing any long-term studies on the
safety
because they don't see any
characteristics of gmos as being unique
or different from other kinds of foods i
have to say that this research gap is
admittedly
not something that i'm very happy about
and definitely an area of research that
i
personally would love to see addressed
so am i saying that there are no
benefits to eating organic
i think there are absolutely some
benefits and personally
i buy some things organic and
something's not organic
in organics it appears that there are
fewer pesticides
and less is probably better and there
also appears to be more antioxidants
which is
often why we eat produce in the first
place
in organic meat there are no antibiotics
or synthetic hormones which
deserves a whole video in itself and
organic farming is often
likely safer for farmers themselves who
are exposed to very high
doses of pesticides and then whether or
not it's better for the environment
really is up for debate that piece has a
lot of spokes to consider
but my overarching message on organics
versus conventional is that
if it comes down to eating fewer
organics or more conventional fruits and
vegetables
i would way rather people buy
conventional
and eat more i don't believe that the
benefits of organics outweigh the
potential benefits of
more produce period especially if you're
washing your food which
we should all be doing anyway finally i
just want to say that sorel mentions
that when she couldn't afford organic
she would buy from the farmer's market
which is generally a suggestion that i
agree with
but it's also been exposed that a lot of
the alleged farmers
at local farmers markets are actually
just buying the produce from the food
terminal
like your local grocery store is and
then they're selling you a
foodie fantasy at a much higher price
so my advice is if how your food is
grown is important to you
and i think that there's a lot of merit
in it being important
to then get to know your farmer find out
exactly how they're farming
and what they're using on their soil and
don't just assume that an alleged
organic food
is inherently safer or healthier period
but organic a lot of people still
believe that it's not important putting
poison on food is not safe that's going
directly in the body no matter how you
label it there's been
fertilizers throughout the ages that
were legal for a while they created so
many complications for humans and then
people were like
ah maybe it's not legal so they
retracted it i don't have time to go
into the history of
pesticides but yes agreed some have
absolutely been deemed unsafe but fyi
organic farmers also use organic
pesticides
and sometimes even in more volume than
conventional
and just because they're natural doesn't
mean
they're inherently safer one example is
rotalone
which comes from plants and was used for
decades as an organic pesticide
and is no longer used in the us because
it has been shown to have parkinson's
like symptoms
in rats so yes over time we are learning
about the safety of pesticide exposure
and that includes natural pesticides
as well please grow your own food it's
really fun okay so i appreciate that
sorel acknowledges her privilege in
being able to buy organic food
but it's important to also note that
growing your own food
is a huge luxury in industrialized
societies as well
not a lot of us own the land or live in
an area to support a diverse set of
crops
or have the time in our busy work week
just trying to pay the bills
to instead feed our own livestock and
grow our own kale
so for some this too is just not a
realistic
viable option anything that i don't know
what's in it i haven't prepared it
myself or if it doesn't have one or two
ingredients in the back i
am not so sure that i want it
so it's these kind of statements that
you know really make me sad
when food and food rules have such a
tight hold on you
social interactions which often surround
food
become a source of major anxiety
this may feel like it's working for
sorel and
this control may feel like a really
helpful coping strategy
but this level of control might also
take up a lot of space in her life
that could easily be diverted to other
joyful
amazing ventures but if i'm going to be
binging i try to eat
as much as possible gluten-free luckily
we just figured out how to make pizza
bases with tapioca flour and coconut
flour
and it tastes delicious brown bread i'm
sorry you want to think it's healthy
it's not grains as possible they they
have to be eliminated okay
so sorrell mentions that she tries to
eliminate grains as one of her food
rules
but if she's going to be binging she
prefers to choose
gluten-free options
i mean this all feels so
exhausting first of all unless you are
celiac
allergic to a grain or have non-sea like
gluten intolerance
there are very few reasons to go
gluten-free i am
so grateful that we have a lot of tasty
gluten-free options on the market now
because
this makes life easier and more
enjoyable
for those who actually need it but if
you're going gluten-free because you
think it's healthier or that'll help you
lose weight
know that the research doesn't really
support this
at all in fact a lot of gluten-free
products arguably have
more additives and less fiber than their
gluten-filled
counterparts grains are actually rich
sources of fiber
b vitamins antioxidants and trace
minerals
and there's tons of evidence to suggest
that a diet rich in whole grains
can help to reduce the risk of heart
disease type 2 diabetes and obesity
and may also help improve digestion so
the fact that sorel is
binging on gluten-free pasta not only
just points out the unsustainability of
her restrictive diet
but also reveals a lot of gaps in her
logic around general nutrition
and food we have been eating grains for
a very short period of time
compared to the evolution of us as a
body and we're not quite adapt at eating
grains just yet
i don't know about that my gluten-filled
bread recipe calls for
flour water yeast and salt we haven't
adapted to that
but we've adapted to eating all of the
things that are found in a loaf of
commercial gluten-free
bread i don't know i'm just poking fun
here because the whole
we have not adapted as a species
argument against modern food
is in my opinion an impossible one to
prove
or refute all i will say is
thank goodness for gluten-free products
especially the tasty ones on the market
but don't choose them because they're
more natural or less
toxic or more like what our ancestors
ate
they're not at all choose a product that
makes you
feel good physically and emotionally and
accept that that is going to be
different
for different people next huge portion
of my diet is
just kind of rep repetitive it's like
veggies veggies veggies veggies and for
breakfast i'll have eggs with rice cake
otherwise
just fish veggies of some sort lots of
greens lots of broccoli
this does sound super repetitive and
i don't know i can't say i like pegged
her as being like a rice cake girl
but anyways sorel definitely loves her
veg which is great
i'm a dietitian i cannot fault somebody
for eating a lot of veg
um and her april wedding today video she
did have a
large jar of salad for lunch and then a
ton of roasted veggies for dinner
definitely exceeding her veggie needs
for the day and then we did get some
eggs at breakfast
like a little homemade hummus at dinner
a banana based smoothie at snack and
even two oreos for dessert
but when i ran her nutrient analysis for
that one day in april
her diet was moderate in carbs high in
fat
around 40 percent largely from the added
olive oil and coconut oil
but then really low in protein just 10
there was also about 60 grams of fiber
so depending on her tolerance that could
be uncomfortable
or it could feel great um regardless
well i
love the veggies and in real life i
never really have to tell people to hold
back on veggies
i think that she could probably pull
back on the volume eating
if she added a little bit more
plant-based protein or
fish or eggs in her day and even a
little more fruit
no cooking with olive oil a lot of
people
are running the impression that it's
okay to cook with olive oil once olive
oil heats up to a certain point it
becomes poisonous so
you are preparing your food healthy by
your topping it with
poison because it's cooked in that i
cook with coconut oil
[Music]
okay back to the poison talk we go
let's make something clear here folks
olive oil is not
poisonous when you heat it up it doesn't
become a trans fat or
toxic to consume if anything
it just becomes a little less nutritious
but olive oil actually has a pretty high
smoke point about
375 to 400 degrees fahrenheit which
makes it a safe choice for most cooking
methods
including pan frying now while research
suggests that cooking olive oil at 465
degrees
fahrenheit for 90 minutes may reduce
some of its anti-inflammatory compounds
you wouldn't even deep fry at that
temperature never mind
pan fry or roast so in reality
olive oil is in my books one of the
healthiest
safest oils that you can cook with if
you want to hear more about some of the
common misconceptions about
oils and fats you can check out my video
right here
i also wonder sometimes if my body shape
and structure my high metabolism
came from my mom's diet when she was
pregnant with me and seven months before
she became pregnant with me she was
living on a diet called
fit for life which was essentially liver
and vegetables and it was
also the concept that if you were eating
carbohydrates you wouldn't mix it with
protein so say you had
fish then you could have salad or if you
had potatoes
then you could have salad but you
couldn't have those three combined
giving your body as least amount of work
to do to digest to get the most
nutrients
i still try to do that as much as
possible not mixing proteins and carbs
guys i just i just can't
uh first of all while we do have some
early research that maternal diet and
pregnancy can have an impact on baby
it's got nothing to do with mom's weight
loss diet having any impact on
the offspring's metabolism if anything
restriction and dieting in pregnancy is
thought to potentially do the opposite
by stimulating the thrifty gene and
putting kids at greater risk of
metabolic syndrome
and weight gain later on as for sorel's
food combining well
i don't know i can't say i'm surprised
you know just add another bogus diet
rule onto the pile until we
only have a handful of foods left that
are
safe to eat now i have already spoken
ad nauseam about food combining here and
here so
i'm not going to belabor this point
anymore
but folks a big reminder your body has
a bunch of different enzymes to break
down different food components
simultaneously eating protein and carbs
at the same time
doesn't create a traffic jam in your gut
and in fact
almost all foods including a lot of
foods that sorel consumes
contain some combination of these
nutrients
so even if you tried really hard to
tease carbs and protein apart for the
sake of better digestion
you likely just could not just topping
things off like hemp seeds sunflower
seeds
sesame seeds avoiding cashews not good
for you
what why what is wrong with cashews
why are they getting you know the short
end of the stick um
i don't know maybe it's because they're
a source of dietary oxalates which is an
anti-nutrient
that binds to calcium and can increase
the risk of kidney stones
i don't know unless you're prone to
kidney stones it's
not really something that you need to
watch if you're eating meat try to have
antibiotic-free grass-fed free-range
meat otherwise i would just stay away
from it because the amount of [ __ ]
that's in it it's just not worth it on
the normal supermarket shelves of meat
this is another really big topic so i'm
just going to try to keep it short and
top level
so again do not shoot me for not
tackling every consideration in these
very complicated convoluted questions
um but first of all i think it's great
that we have so many choices when it
comes to
meat and poultry consume or if we
consume it at all
now research suggests that grass-fed
options do tend to have higher amounts
of vitamin a and e and omega-3s but
we're not talking huge huge huge
differences or even
major sources in the grand scheme of
one's diet so again
you have to really determine if the cost
is worth it for you
now free range chickens for example must
have
access to the outdoors but there are
actually no real standards for
what this even means and how long
they have to be outside can really vary
from farm to farm
as for the antibiotic free claim as it
pertains to meat and poultry
well the big concern with the overuse of
antibiotics is
resistant bacteria which i do believe
is a really big problem but the
important thing to note
is that buying organic or
antibiotic-free doesn't necessarily
preclude you
from that risk one study found that the
frequency of antibiotic resistant e coli
was only slightly lower for chickens
race without antibiotics
compared to conventional chicken this is
why it's really important to simply
follow
proper food safety protocols to prevent
your family from getting sick from a
food that
may be contaminated with antibiotic
resistant bacteria
now i know that my vegan friends will
say it's impossible to eat meat
sustainably
or humanely but i agree with sorel that
if you do
choose to eat meat it's ideal to choose
the best quality meat raised the most
humanely and in the healthiest way
possible
obviously this comes with added cost so
my take home message is that if you
choose to eat meat and you like it
to use higher quality meat that you can
afford as a garnish
or accent to the meal and rely more
regularly and more heavily
on plant-based protein instead now
obviously this is a bit of a different
format from my usual videos
but since i briefly touched on her
wedding day video
i figured i would also briefly touch on
her three-day water fast
and acknowledging how long this video
was already i will do everything in my
power to keep
my thoughts short basically in this
video
sorel takes on a three day water fast
which her boyfriend claims is for
general gut health
to feel better and to give one's body a
reset
most significantly her boyfriend who she
describes as a biohacker
talks about the benefits of fasting as
inducing autophagy
so autophagy is the body's natural
process of cleaning
and recycling cells in the body as a
self-preservation mechanism
to remove dysfunctional cells and
regenerate
newer healthier ones research on
autophagy is still in its infancy but
there is some exciting evidence
suggesting that it may help to remove
cancer cells
improve inflammation and protect against
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's
one 2018 review of the existing research
suggested that
fasting may induce autophagy
however because the research in this
area is emerging
not a lot of human studies exist as the
majority of the research that we do have
has been done on animals or in a lab now
fasting in general does have some
research to support it for reducing
insulin resistance
improving inflammation improving heart
health markers
and promoting weight loss animal
research also suggests that it may help
to delay aging
and improve longevity but the jury is
really out when it comes to
humans so i am definitely keeping my
finger on the pulse on this emerging
area of health
i don't believe that fasting is for
everyone whether that's like a longer
three-day cleanse
or something like intermittent fasting
and i do believe that it may
have a tendency to promote very
unhealthy habits in certain populations
i have promised you a whole video on
intermittent fasting which i promise
i will get to some time after this baby
arrives
but one thing i do want to comment on
was sorelle's suggestion
that the reason that our ancestors had
lower rates of disease
was because they fasted to purge their
bodies of damaged
cells uh not likely
well i believe there's probably multiple
reasons for the health status of our
ancestors
i just want to flag the average life
expectancy
of a paleolithic era human was around
35 and before the advent of farming
it was even younger so yeah most of us
are not getting cancer or heart disease
in our 30s
either regardless of whether or not we
fast
just saying obviously i've outlined in
detail some of the
misinformation or what i see as
potentially problematic delivery
when it comes to sorel's channel but is
there anything
positive that we can take away from this
well
i will say that in addition to the
beautiful beautiful imagery that she
shares
there is something very romantic and
encouraging
about her newfound love of cooking and
enjoying a meal with friends
let's take a look i honestly don't think
i fully understood
how unreal it is to have the opportunity
to
put so much love and care into audition
and to share it with other others
i used to take great pride in the fact
that i didn't like cooking
i thought it got in the way of my
material success and now everything is
reversing obviously
life is putting things into perspective
and living simply and sharing joys with
people is so
nice okay so as somebody who also
sometimes feels like a bit of a hamster
on a productivity wheel
i can appreciate the simple joys that
slowing down to prepare
and enjoy a meal with others can bring i
think
too many of us rush through our days
with food just kind of tagging along for
the ride
and we give very little appreciation and
energy to mealtimes
out of fear that we're being
unproductive but don't forget that
food is the only reason that we can be
productive
not to mention it holds cultural social
and emotional benefits as well
so do not sell yourself short on your
experiences with food
i get that sometimes eating slowly and
deliberately is a privileged experience
and
so many of us need to multitask
due to socioeconomic considerations but
i do believe that we can still place
greater value as a society on sitting
down to a meal sorel has also said that
when you do
indulge not to punish bad behavior and
that
she doesn't believe guilt or shame have
any place with food now i do agree
though i really don't like the idea of
this being
bad behavior and i'm also unsure if her
actions support that message
but i will say it's a good message to
share
nonetheless in conclusion while i can't
say i really agree with sorel's
inflexible
and dogmatic approach to wellness i want
to reiterate that
she is seemingly on her own journey to
figure out
what feels best to her her dietary
nutrition guidelines
are in no way the bible for good health
and while she isn't wrong about
everything
we don't have enough evidence to suggest
that she is right
either in fact in the world of nutrition
research
we don't actually have a lot of research
to prove much
a lot of it comes down to what feels
good to you physically and mentally
and i'm just going out on a limb here
but i would say that
keeping tabs on all of these rules
characterizing your world and most foods
within it as
toxic or poison and restricting yourself
to such
a narrow number of tolerated safe foods
would be mentally exhausting socially
isolating
and massively anxiety provoking for most
people
so if it works for sorel i mean it works
for me but
i do not believe this all of this
would be healthy for the vast majority
of you watching right now
and on that note that is all for today
folks if you like this video
please don't forget to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below if
you have
any other youtubers or videos that you
want me to review
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
you